hello reject nation this is Greg Alva
here
Stacey Oh Howard is here with us father
on Instagram and Twitter people and
she's also on Miss movies channel on
YouTube
weekly Wednesday's is what I call those
segments Stacy let me explain this to
you a year ago I saw these three
commercials from the Philippines for a
Filipino chain restaurant called jolly
be jolly be jolly be yes you'll find
many of them in the Greater San Gabriel
area jolly B is like a fast-food
restaurant and they put together these
commercials that are like short films
and sometimes they're incredibly
emotional sometimes you're just loving
these are their Valentine series here
and unlike a lot of other people who
check out these jollibee commercials I'm
actually half Filipino so I connect with
these people no no I found it at a
Mexican bar Oh mm-hmm paid good money
for it okay we're gonna check out all
three and we're gonna talk about all
three today
let's talk about this and love and life
this first one here Stacey is called
status probably subtitled
[Music]
but it'll go you know nectar and they've
spent so much time looking for enough
[Music]
I've gone through date after date after
date are you on the day with her why
that's confusing
this is really working who doesn't
remember either so he could run away
she's so pretty
yeah I ain't gonna even pretty peep and
that's if I'm lucky I'll get my mommy
mean son you can't even see don't know
over that advice letting me put it
she in love with a hamburger no his
commercial that's true that is true like
the wise brother did she has daddy
issues because of you yeah
also it's never just a guy dad and they
realized why do I keep looking for love
in all the wrong places
their own people
[Music]
with her dad this is that's the pop
twins there's an accessory
[Music]
oh she needs to learn to just appreciate
the blood he has gotta love her family
yeah then she'll find love she has
family in love and Frenchman
[Music]
hey that's a great message right there I
like that
I love that they're like let's have a
family dinner in Charlie yeah man [ __ ]
celery fried chicken yeah you'll love it
you'll love it
[Music]
she found herself self-love
[Music]
he's cute turn around girl no man even
without a love life you have love in
your life oh what a great message that's
a great message that's pretty sweet
that's a great message come on you're
really gonna get an American commercial
like that I I was actually just gonna
say that looks exactly like half the
McDonald's commercials that I've seen
half the McDonald's commercial the other
half aesthetic but the story about the
McGriddle and it was like two people
that work in McDonald and she's on
seeing him and she's trying to tell him
like pay attention to what's in front of
you you know she's like eating the
McGriddle and he's like huh and it's
just like that it's like fine love we do
not don't expect it I don't know I don't
really remember your McGriddle
commercial remember just when I'm
getting here I think that's a beautiful
message it's good it's kind of like a
psychological story in a way because so
many times you'll meet people men and
women who are looking for love because
they don't feel the love from their
family and there's all this
psychological problematic upbringing so
they're trying to fix it by finding the
right person but if you can learn to
appreciate the current life you have now
self love yourself then you can find a
healthy true love do you have self love
seek validation everywhere I go I do
believe in the message of that I also
believe in the message of food I'm
charlie ug Charlie beat they're
delicious it's like Filipino fast food
but they have Fried Chicken they got
burgers i got fries i know what this
woman loves to eat she can tack on a
heavy-ass fried meal
Oh jolly be with you yeah let's go woman
with me let's watch another one Stacy
I'm excited all right this one's called
signs signs is there aliens in it I wish
is it but Mel Gibson's in this Filipino
that would be so they're all kind of
different
if someone sings star and I think that's
a beautiful name you're not known enough
that so now the one for you that's a
terrible method that's a terrible memory
[Music]
[Music]
I love it he's in slow-mo you gotta talk
to him stop just stare
[Music]
he's like really comfortable who is your
soulmate what these are signs lady oh
[Music]
this is gonna be hard for you I feel
he's gay okey universe put the ditch in
and join me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see starting out below that's me go
Stacey what are you talking about her I
guess so we're gonna have a conversation
they have spaghetti they're not really
[Music]
oh that guy's too I think that's one of
her friends
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it was him then it was him who's the
third guy it's like a Salt whist
[Music]
I love it I love the cheese
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see it is just like a McDonald's they
face red there's a vet yeah this signs
man misled you true love will find you
those signs may have misled you
true love will find you this is a rare
scenario for a guy yeah normally dudes
are just friend zone I'm the master of
getting friends oh and I could teach a
class on it oh it's easy you care about
the girl you talk to her about her
feelings and you show her attention and
then you're just a good friend they
don't want to ruin that friendship with
you that's how you do it man some girls
respond to it it's rare but I've been
friends oh by many girls I love it I'm
that I'm the what's this guy's name
who's the guy had John's I'm telling you
Stacey last year the ones I watched I
watched to that happy balding neighbors
because they were not like corny
romantic ones like I'm enjoying these
but the ones last year were like a
heartbreaking serious-ass ones that
really got me in those yeah and if you
see my reaction it's nice that this year
jolly bees mixed it up with some actual
loving stuff for Valentine's Day
[Music]
this is female-driven commercials female
empowerment here because first one we
watched was about a girl learning to
love herself second one was about
knowing how to truly pay attention to
the signs and to the guys who are
actually interested in you I think these
are more psychological than people
jacket over you and touch your boob he
was totally touched me yeah he's touched
my boob thanks Oh feel like that's how
little muscle I have these are
psychological studies because girls are
drawn to emotionally unavailable guys
all the time he's emotionally available
he's putting himself out there it's good
thing she's opening up her
because she's settling for second place
but she reacted to a well man I'm gonna
start using that I'm into it spa Getti
What did he say it was like a relaxing
food yeah I think there was just a good
line than throwing there to get a
close-up shot of a delicious looking
spaghetti I had spaghetti yesterday oh I
love spaghetti it was you put butter in
your spaghetti you're gonna die check
your cholesterol
all right here last one
homecoming okay get it another story
[Music]
Oh an old couple the Filipino face the
HP well
[Music]
wait what was you got walk up to that
girl
my cufflink I really needed that thing
[Laughter]
this guy's just feeling really lonely on
Valentine's Day
she looks like gum what's her face in
the breakfast look I've just got the
makeover with like our headbands oh yeah
yeah
[Music]
you gotta get started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's like a flashback
[Music]
when they were younger
[Music]
I think she's what the guy is kind of a
dick look she's like was like I'm
precious babe I think that's her parents
or something his parents
you're supposed to help me he's gonna
help her them
wow he is efficient he's super duper
efficient
[Music]
is the buffest
urn I've ever seen going home with this
guy yeah someone's a dick don't be with
them well not this guy's sad I love how
she's she's dressed like it's in the 50s
that's what I'm thinking this is a
flashback
oh maybe yeah why else will they show
the old couple I'm here for you I'm here
for you the cops
[Music]
[Music]
they look good I wish they'd CGI young
[Music]
it's not sure what if you're like
fighting tired people heart attacks will
have heart attacks they go to sleep
permanently sometimes jolly man this guy
was a buff ass nerd that's what I was
really taking for him a dude I know he
like drops everything seems like buff
strong he is you're so strong at least I
thought this was the weakest one of them
all I mean it's a cool message to know
that their true love did last forever
highschool sweethearts I don't meet too
many actual highschool sweethearts
I like that they did like a momento
thing they like worked backwards yeah
cool structures where it is and what's
happening what timeline yeah because I
mean I picked up on it pretty quick you
were like no but you predicted the
burger I did predict the burger I did
I love these cuz I haven't been to the
phillipines since I was three years old
holy you would fit this commercial makes
me think that the way to find true love
take a check the Jollibee yeah it's like
cost-efficient and easy to find love at
jollibee Navin man jollibee in so many
years
Stacy you got to go I want you were
talking about possibly moving to
Glendale there's at least to England the
Filipinos are everywhere in Glendale we
own that it's Filipinos and Armenians
seriously it really is if you're from
the Philippines watching this video move
to Glendale Eagle Rock area you'll fit
right in with all the Filipinos
Armenians
my whole Filipino song yeah this is my
nan girlfriend white friend here with me
today
guys thanks for telling us this was out
happy Valentine's Day to the whole world
lord knows I'm gonna be broken that day
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification button get
notified every time one of our videos is
up follow Stacy Howard at Stacy o Howard
on Instagram and Twitter yo and check
out our patreon a lot of fun exclusive
perks over there and exclusive videos
good yeah I know this is awkward
movement like my shoulders tense and I
do this is up in my hand which I be more
expressive with my hands I feel like
it's the key to a good president
presenter what if we just pointed the
camera out like a boy band and you know
how they get like close you know